[Musique]
il n'y a ni château ni resto mais le vin
certifié bio qu'on fabrique ici est
considéré par les connaisseurs comme un
des meilleurs au québec la grappe
je pense que les émulations à un mois
des vendanges les patrons du vignoble
sont aux aguets le raisin est magnifique
il arrive à maturité et il commence à
attirer les prédateurs les maires le
menace on les chasse avec des sons
d'oiseaux effrayés par des rapaces on
installe aussi des clôtures électrifiées
pour garder les ratons laveurs et les
dead sauvage à distance
mais ce n'est pas la menace la plus
sérieuse à laquelle le couple de
vignerons a dû faire face cette année
c'est une année saison dont on va se
rappeler pour diverses raisons
vers une équipe est aimablement long du
show ce printemps ils se demandaient
s'il pourrait accueillir les deux
employés mexicaine qui travaillent pour
eux depuis cinq ans ils ont finalement
réussi à obtenir leur laissez passer ou
début de mai c'est important pour moi c
est pour le travail pour l'argent camper
ici et pour nos familles en plus les
viticulteurs ont pu compter sur des amis
des clients des connaisseurs pour les
aider bénévolement dans les champs oui
on a eu tout de suite une grosse vague
de soutien d'amour de cette toute notre
clientèle les amis donc ça soit les
sommeliers que ce soit des serveurs tous
ces gens qui sont retrouvés sans emploi
qui voulaient donner un coup de main
mckeever uniquement accueilli à bras
ouverts pour que je passe par deux jours
semaines ici ceux sur le lit de montréal
devait se rendre en europe pour un stage
de formation
le voyage a été annulé pour cause de
pandémie
il a donc demandé à venir ici pour en
savoir plus sur la fabrication du vin en
biodynamie on comprend mieux toute
l'évolution si on comprend mieux les
impacts de chaque action ces vignerons
là donc c'est certain que dans un point
de vue de sommellerie
on est plus apte à conseiller après déjà
en apprendre plus sur la culture de la
vigne en général comment fonctionne
aussi qu'est-ce qu'elle a besoin un peu
plus dans les conditions souvent que les
gens considèrent extrêmes comme le
québec
je pense que je vais faire ici c'est
avoir une fondation plus solide que
juste l'intuition pierre lire des livres
avec leurs trois hectares de chardonnay
de ses valets de pineau les vignerons de
farnham arrive à produire près de vingt
mille bouteilles par année une
production vendue à des restaurateurs et
des acheteurs privés cette année ne fera
pas exception
malgré les déboires dans le milieu de la
restauration
au début on pensait qu'on allait
possiblement avoir un peu plus de vingt
disponibles parce que la restauration
tout seul mais il ya quand même les
restaurateurs prennent leur commande
puis le vin et le vin sort quand même
donc on n'a vraiment pas eu de suspense
les gens avaient particulièrement soir
[Musique]
tous les producteurs de la région n'ont
pas la même chance certains dépendent
davantage des banquets des mariages pour
écouler leurs produits des activités
pratiquement aboli par la pandémie
le couple super mario constate que la
production à petite échelle les sert à
merveille pendant cette période
perturbée qu'elle ment plus épanouie
noter que sa fille
[Musique]
on a vu que oui on a pu traverser la
crise à cause un peu les kills la taille
qu'on avait on voulait de vignerons
parce qu'on est passionné par le métier
et on s'est toujours dit qu'on va faire
ce qu'on veut au niveau de notre passion
en premier et que les on espère que
cette passion va amener à une qualité
qui va permettre à faire vivre
l'entreprise derrière c'est la meilleure
place de patron le meilleur vin
[Rires]
[Musique]